bonjour à tous arnold scharzenegger
l'homme qui est passé de mister univers
acteur à succès à gouverneur de
californie nous dit ceux qui disent que
c'est impossible ne devrait pas
interrompre ce qu'ils essayent de le
rendre possible
et j'aime beaucoup cette citation parce
que aujourd'hui on utilise le moins
possible un petit peu à tort et à
travers pour tout et n'importe quoi et
on a tendance à tomber dans cette
illusion de confondre ce qui est
compliqué parfois complexe parfois
difficile avec ce qui est vraiment
impossible et ça ça nous freine dans nos
projets professionnels et dans nos
projets personnels et je trouve ça
d'autant plus dommage qui ayant été
magicien créateur d'illusions et
entrepreneurs pendant dix ans tout ce
qui touche à l'illusion et à
l'impossible ça me titille un petit peu
donc aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous aider à
sortir de cette illusion pour vous
puissiez donner vie à vos projets et
attendre le succès est tel que vous le
définissez mais avant ça j'aimerais vous
montrer jusqu'où nous les magiciens on
peut aller dans l'illusion de
l'impossible imaginons que je pas
choisir une carte un spectateur
voilà vous êtes chez vous donc ça va
être un petit peu plus difficile mais on
va imaginer ensemble
d'abord je commence par montrer que
toutes les cartes sont différentes sinon
ça sent vraiment larnack si je fais
choisir dans un paquet de cartes où
toutes les cartes sont identiques
évidemment d'habitude je demande aux
gens de s'arrêter alors que je fais
passer les cartes dans ma main là je
vais simplement coupé n'importe où et on
va imaginer que c'est la carte que vous
avez choisi je vous laisse le temps de
bien la garder en tête et parfois les
gens me disent est ce que ça arrive que
tu te trompes dans tes illusions et la
réponse et ça arrive parfois mais on
trouve toujours un moyen de se retourner
de trouver une solution dans cette
situation un petit peu compliqué et
qu'il n'est pas impossible donc
imaginons par exemple que j'ai dans ma
poche une carte de couleur bleu donc
déjà on est mal parti parce que sa carte
était votre carte était rouge et en plus
c'est même pas la bonne face c'est un
joker c'est pas la carte que vous avez
choisi en tout cas je ne crois pas
maintenant la caractéristique du joker
et c'est ça qui devient intéressant ce
qui a peut se transformer en n'importe
quelle carte
donc même si je m'étais trompé je
pourrais me sortir de cette situation un
petit peu compliqué en transformant
cette carte en la vôtre
regardez bien et je ne suis pas sûr de
savoir quelle carte vous avez choisi
mais il me semble que c'est le roi de
coeur c'est bien ça donc on voit ce
genre d'illusions on se dit comment il a
fait et je peux vous dire que c'est
avant tout un état d'esprit
parce qu'en tant que magicien on va
imaginer des choses qui sur le papier
sont forcément impossible sont des
illusions
donc on va pas à créer des choses qui
sont probables sinon ça serait pas très
impressionnant mais ensuite on va
rentrer dans le détail et avec notre
créativité
on va décortiquer le problème on va
regarder les éléments 1 1
jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve une solution qui
soit viable qui donne l'illusion de
l'impossible et ça c'est un petit peu
pareil dans la vie de tous les jours
qu'on a des projets ils peuvent paraître
au premier abord un petit peu impossible
mais quand on va rentrer dans le détail
on va pouvoir trouver des solutions
maintenant là où je trouve ça un petit
peu dommage c'est que j'entends beaucoup
de personnes qui disent oui mais moi je
suis pas créatif je suis pas magicien
parfois on pense un petit peu aux grands
noms les einstein les steve jobs les
picasso et on a l'impression qu'on n'a
pas cette capacité créative mais ça
c'est faux ça a été prouvé déjà
fermeture des milliers d'années c'est
comme ça que nous les humains nous avons
évolué on a survécu et déjà nos ancêtres
trouver des nouvelles façons de se
nourrir construisait des outils pour
mieux vivre et aujourd'hui au quotidien
vous trouvez déjà un paquet d'idées je
sais pas si vous en rendez compte
mais quand vous trouver une nouvelle
façon d'aller au boulot qui est plus
rapide
vous êtes créatif vous trouver une
solution à un problème quand vous
trouvez pas une nouvelle façon de
réviser vos examens ou que vous réparez
quelque chose chez vous que ce soit un
pied de chaise ou une fuite de lavabos
avec un peu de scotch et trois bouts de
ficelle
vous êtes créatif et la bonne nouvelle
c'est que la créativité c'est un muscle
se dire que plus vous allez là
travaillez plus vous allez travailler
sur cette compétence plus pouvoir
trouver des idées et des meilleures
solutions
et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que
ça veut dire que vous allez aussi
pouvoir vous êtes inquiets des projets
de plus grande envergure qui paraissent
au premier abord un petit peu impossible
donc en fait avec la créative
et vous allez pouvoir dessiner votre
futur papa repas une solution après
l'autre vous allez pouvoir avancer dans
vos projets que ce soit des projets
comme vivre à l'étranger monter sa
propre boîte ou fonder sa famille de
produits peu importe quels sont vos
projets vous allez pouvoir le faire avec
cette créativité
mais au premier abord ça paraît toujours
un petit peu impossible
on se dit alors c'est quoi ce sac de
noeuds on a l'impression qu'on va jamais
pouvoir y arriver
et en tant que magicien quand on crée
une illusion
c'est exactement la proche qu'on a c'est
ne pas regarder ce sac de noeuds comme
un obstacle infranchissable
mais justement on va à les décortiquer
on va les défaire les noeuds un parent
imaginons par exemple qu'on veuille
faire apparaître un objet on va se dire
ok vu que j'ai pas de pouvoirs magiques
désolé je vous spoiler un petit peu il
faudra que cet objet soit caché quelque
part peut-être sur moi peut-être sous la
table donc déjà il ya un premier
problème est là on va pas prendre le
projet en entier on va regarder chacun
des problèmes donc déjà on résout le
problème
ok maintenant j'ai trouvé où est ce que
j'allais me cacher deuxième problème
à un moment donné à falloir que je me
penche pour le prendre là on va le voir
donc je vais résoudre ce problème ça
veut dire que je vais réfléchir comment
je vais diriger l'attention des gens
peut-être je vais les faire en sorte
qu'ils regardent à tel endroit au moment
où je me penche etc et on se dit encore
un autre problème me dire oui mais une
fois que tu as pris l'objet est que les
gens ont regardé ailleurs ça va se voir
tu l'as dans la main donc on va devoir
imaginer un moyen de le cacher de l'an
palme et de le mettre derrière un autre
objet etc
mais on va pas s'arrêter à se dire oh là
là ça en sac de noeuds on peut rien
faire au contraire on va démêler les
noeuds un par un on va résoudre un
problème après l'autre jusqu'à ce qu'on
arrive à une solution et ça on peut tous
le faire ça soit en magie ou dans votre
vie dans vos projets personnels ou
professionnels
maintenant c'est vrai il ya des choses
qui sont vraiment impossible
jamais il ya des choses les lois de la
physique ne le permettent pas
ou alors tout simplement n'a pas la
technologie aujourd'hui pour le faire
mais je pense que dans 95 % des cas on
tombe dans cette illusion
on se dit c'est impossible alors que
c'est juste complexe donc c'est vraiment
un état d'esprit à avoir a intégré et
moi cet état d'esprit j'ai dû l'intégrer
un moment de ma vie très précis je m'en
souviens très bien c'était un tournant
c'était même pas d'ailleurs pour créer
une illusion mais c'était à un moment où
j'allais je voulais devenir magicien
professionnel je m'en souviens j'étais
en equateur alors je mets un peu de
contexte
j'avais fait des études d'économie et
après mes études je suis parti en
amérique latine tout seul avec mon bac
bac et pendant quelques mois je faisais
déjà des petits tours de magie à des
amis dans les auberges
mais au bout d'un moment je me suis dit
bon ça serait bien d'avoir mon premier
boulot de magicien je m'étais fixé cet
objectif et après avoir tapé à toutes
les portes de la ville et avoir essuyé
un paquet de refuge et enfin trouvé un
barca dit oui on cherche un magicien
truc complètement improbable mais avait
un projet de café théâtre avait déjà
quelques artistes il y avait une
condition est d'ailleurs plusieurs
conditions
ils ont dit il faut être capable de
faire un spectacle devant une centaine
de personnes environ quatre fois par
semaine pendant 20 minutes sous une
forme de numéros de 20 minutes bien
ficelé je n'avais aucune idée de comment
faire ça parce que je faisais du
close-up la magie de près je faisais des
petits tours à droite à gauche et jamais
vraiment de numéro et jamais à cette
fréquence mais j'ai dit je suis votre
homme c'est mon métier engagé moi il ya
aucun problème je vous garantis que ça
va être un succès donc déjà ça c'est
déjà un petit peu l'état d'esprit qu'il
faut avoir parce que déjà à ce moment là
et ça ce que font beaucoup les magiciens
ont dit oui c'est possible
alors que on n'a aucune idée de comment
le faire parce qu'on sait qu'on va
toujours trouver une solution
donc je vais dans les espèces de petits
cabanons kim avait loué pour l'occasion
je sors mon eeepc donc oui c'était une
autre époque
et là je regarde toutes les petites
vidéos les pdf 2
aj que j'avais déjà à droite à gauche et
je crée ce numéro de 20 minutes
mais vraiment je me creuse la tête je
mets un tour après l'autre jeu je crée
un personnage en plus un personnage qui
était serveur là je parlais pas espagnol
donc je vais rajouter de la musique
parce que du coup je dois faire un
numéro en musique un numéro silencieux
et je présente ce numéro toute la
semaine et à la fin de la semaine la
directrice artistique du lieu m'appelle
dans son bureau alors elle parlait pas
très bien anglais moi je parlais pas
très bien espagnol on devait communiquer
un petit peu avec des gestes et là elle
me dit you show donc ton spectacle a
commencé 17 bail en exagérant pour me
dire que mon spectacle était bien nulle
et en fait mais en fait ça m'a brisé le
coeur à ce moment là parce que moi j'y
croyais vraiment je commençais vraiment
à croire ce projet de vie d'être
magicien professionnel
elle a balayé ça j'allais dire d'un
revers de main abalessa d'un geste
demain et quand je sortis du bureau
bon déjà merci à notre état pour ce
conseil constructif mais je me suis dit
rétrospectivement je voyais que je me
suis dit j'ai deux façons de réagir à
cette situation soit je me dis ouais
mais elle a rien compris
oui mais moi je fais preuve close up
c'est de la magie de presse sapa de la
scène oui mais quand c'est moi qui crée
mes propres trucs ça marche pas les gens
aiment pas faut juste que je copie ou
alors je pouvais me dire bon déjà
j'encaisse ce que ça on a tendance à
oublier un petit peu faut encaisser ce
genre de
du coup et ensuite je vais tout mettre à
plat sur la table et je vais essayer
d'ajuster certains éléments en trouvant
des solutions
évidemment si au vu de ce que je vous
raconte aujourd'hui
vous imaginez bien quel état d'esprit
j'ai décidé d'intégrer et je pèse ce mot
décider parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment un choix qu'on peut faire on
peut décider d'avoir cet état d'esprit
ce soir vous avez vu des speakers avec
des parcours atypique qui ont décidé
d'avoir cet état d'esprit ils ont fait
ce choix pour attendre leurs objectifs
et leurs projets de vie concrétiser
aussi leur rêve et ça vous pouvez le
faire également
et donc pour terminer l'histoire au
final ça s'est bien terminé puisque
quand j'ai tout mis à plat
j'ai pu mettre mon ego de côté ce qui
n'est pas toujours facile demander de
l'aide aussi à d'autres personnes à des
artistes et là on a compris plein de
trucs on a compris que voilà certes
illusions et dont les voyez pas du fond
de la salle
on a d'autres où les gens étaient trop
près dans le mauvais angle donc y voyait
un peu trop ce qui se passait parfois je
laissais pas le temps où j'en applaudir
non plus donc ça crée une ambiance un
petit peu bizarre dans la salle et
rosita elle dans son bureau
impression que le spectacle était ou
comme elle m'a dit et on a pu réajuster
chacun des éléments
j'ai eu mon premier boulot de magicien
sur celle là bas pendant un mois et demi
avant de continuer mon périple
et ça c'est la première paye de magicien
que j'ai eue de toute ma vie
25 dollars en pièces est de une c'était
l'ultime fierté à cette époque là cet
endroit là c'était beaucoup
un jour mais dans le contexte limite je
mettais un petit peu de côté et si vous
voulez je peux même vous montrer une
illusion que je faisais à cet endroit là
ce que je faisais c'est que je prenais
un papier alors je prends plus petits
papiers que ce que j'avais à l'époque
parce qu'on filme de près et je plié ce
papier dans une forme
artistique très précises bon je plie au
pif
est ce que je faisais c'est que je
donner l'illusion j'espère qu'on va bien
voir à la caméra que je pouvais faire
voler ce papier regardez déjà le faire
bouger un petit peu
et petit à petit le faire voler est-ce
qu'on avait compris c'est que c'était
plus intéressant d'en lever la main pour
montrer qui a rien attaché au dessus ou
ni en dessous ni là et ensuite je
prenais le temps de bien le montrer face
caméra et pas de caméra je le fais ça
pour vous regarder je fais pas ça à
travers temps pas non je pense qu'il
n'ya pas trente six mille façons de
réagir à des situations négatives quand
on a des obstacles ou quand on veut
mener un projet à bien soit on fait
partie de ces gens là qui trouve
toujours des excuses
on connaît tous ces gens là on peut leur
proposer n'importe quoi une fête de fin
d'année ils vont vous dire ah ouais mais
moi j'ai pas le budget on va leur dire
non mais c'est pas grave on peut faire
des trucs nous mêmes un mais je sais pas
faire on va leur dire non mais on peut
apprendre et puis je connais un mec mais
j'ai pas le temps trouve toujours avec
des oui mais des excuses qu'ils font qui
bloque le projet ou qui rajoute des
obstacles ou alors on peut faire partie
de ces gens là qui trouve toujours une
situation qui trouve toujours un moyen
de surmonter un obstacle même quand ils
sont dos au mur même coincé dans une
impasse si vous êtes à la c'est vraiment
compliqué sauf si away la s'avère
impossible à moins que je connais ce
mec-là qui connaît une méthode ont
trouvé le moyen incroyable de surmonter
ces obstacles la question que j'ai pour
vous aujourd'hui c'est quel genre de
personne vous voulez être
et rappelez vous c'est un choix donc
pour vous aux arts et métiers qu'ils
allaient créer littéralement et
métaphoriquement l'époux de demain
qu'elle ait créé les technologies de
demain et bien plus mais pour ceux qui
nous regardent à la maison et qu'ils
disent oui mais moi je suis pas
ingénieur je suis pas magicien je pas
spécialement créatif je peux pas faire
la différence je suis là pour vous
dire que si vous pouvez faire la
différence juste avec cet état d'esprit
de toujours imaginer qu'il y à une
solution à un problème vous pouvez avoir
des idées trouver des idées à chacun de
vos problèmes et ça ça va vous aider à
débloquer des situations ça risque de
vous surprendre parce que parfois on a
des changements plus grand que ce qu'on
attend qu'on a cet état d'esprit et
qu'on trouve des petites solutions et ça
va aussi inspirer les gens dans votre
entourage à faire de même à mettre leur
créativité en mode own si j'ose dire on
se met tous dans cet état d'esprit et je
pense vraiment que si on se met dans cet
état d'esprit
si on décide tous d'intégrer cette façon
de voir la vie de voir nos projets et
d'imaginer que rien est impossible alors
on va pouvoir co créer ensemble un futur
plus optimistes merci